so you might think why have you got a
problem with monk mode if you have
benefited from it so much and it was
such a powerful productivity tool for
you it's precisely monk Mode's reliable
Effectiveness creates a problem because
the dark side is that addictive
lifestyle thing monk mode justifies a
retreat from life and risk and self
Adventure as it justifies it as
self-development and it makes you feel
Noble in isolation so much so that it
can become hard to bring yourself back
out and this means that if you already
have a tendency to live a sheltered
slightly unsocial life you're
encouraging yourself to further
absconded away from ever building a real
life support network which is ultimately
the thing you need the most in the long
run